hi everybody I'm going to refresh this
real quick go back to my title slide
this is actually really great because
it's a little bit of glitch art like
right in the middle of my presentation
that's completely unplanned I love it so
here's the agenda here's what we're
going to talk about i also have a lot of
chords up here i'm here to talk to you
guys about math art and code and one of
those things may not seem like the
others but hopefully by the end of this
talk you'll sort of understand where I'm
coming from with this weird transitive
property equation if you think about
color palettes right so mass equals art
is pretty great there's a lot of math
being out of inside of art and there's a
lot of art that's made out of math color
palettes if you want to make something
visually pleasing you usually have to
follow a mathematical principle for
split complimentary or compound or
triads there's a lot of math that goes
into just color I do you think about
music musics really amazing it make you
feel sorrowful or triumphant but when
you get down to it it's just data it's a
time signature and a scale and it's
points on that scale which are data
points or notes gang a bunch of those up
and you have a chord and then you can
give that to anybody and if they can
render that I play an instrument they
get to actually recreate that music
anywhere and it's the same thing with
code art you can make it in JavaScript
share it with the world seven billion
people can look at it different medium
but same general principle hello
everybody I was echoey I'm John Brown
and I'm from Portland Oregon which is
about as far from here you can get on
the continental United States so I've
had a long flight I work at a place
where I get to lead a team that gets to
play with new and emerging tech and use
them in creative ways and also work on
our active retail experiences what that
means is I do a lot of stuff front-end
back-end hardware software and I do a
lot of really cool stuff and more and
more and more I'm doing it with just
JavaScript and I'm going to talk to you
guys about a few projects
that are essentially one hundred percent
JavaScript but I'm really rat or that I
think are really rad i'm really proud of
but at night i work with the group in
portland that does all kinds of code art
and generative art and i'm one of the
sort of leaders of that community that I
put on events that are community art
projects I take part in those I put on
smaller projects and I'm a digital
artist and I'm really proud to say that
and I have the pedigree I really feel
like I can say this because like all
great artists I've dropped out of art
school two times my mom's not happy with
that slide so these are a few selected
mathworks I play a lot with math and
this is an exploration of sine and
cosine perfectly said sine and cosine
its most basic is rotation and it's
circular movement and you can create
amazing things just by layering and I'm
actually really proud to be here today
I'm kind of bummed that I'm not in
Portland right now because there's a art
show going on visions of tomorrow's it's
actually starts tomorrow but I have a
piece in there and it's a generative art
piece and it is hanging up alongside
sculptures oil paintings mixed-media
just I just like to talk i just wanted
to point it out because it's it's one of
these things where people a lot of times
don't think digital art is true art but
it really is it's recognized by all the
important people in life again so why am
I here well i'm at a javascript
conference talking about art seems a
little weird well if we go back to this
the title to talk we are talked a little
bit about math and art art encode i feel
like these two things are very
intertwined if you want to explore them
if you want to try being an artist or if
you are an artist learning is way more
fun if you're making art if you think
about if you want to if you have a dream
in the middle of the night and you want
to create it and it involves websockets
that's rad artistic prior it's this
around artistic project do you think I
should use web sockets for this unlike
it work where it's a man-date so now
we're using web sockets now we're using
web sockets and
you have to learn those get to go read
tech docs you need to read some
tutorials now you get to explore and try
a bunch of new things and the outcome
doesn't really matter because it's your
project and you're just trying things
and even along the wave and the things
are broken to take a glitchy screen you
can still create beautiful things with
art and so that leads me to also freedom
of personal projects if you're making
art you're very rarely unfortunately
going to be making it for a paying
client so you get to do anything you
want anything you can dream you can try
and recreate there's any kind of analog
from the fine art world in the
traditional art world in digital art you
can do 3d printing for sculptures you
can do a watercolor like canvas work and
then there's things that you can't do in
the fine art traditional world you can
do in digital art it's also a lot of new
problems that come up when you're making
things creatively and one really rad
like segment of that is is that when you
go to work and let's take a different
example let's say you're working an
e-commerce platform if the payment goes
through the payment portal cool done if
it doesn't that's the that's the other
answer its binary but if you're making
art good explore and you get to try all
kinds of different things it's it's the
line right good how is this color
palette making me feel there are too
many particles on this stage it's a
bunch of different problems you have to
solve and you have to use a different
part of your brain and I don't buy into
like the left brain right brain idea I
think that's been debunked a lot but you
definitely get to flex different
creative skills problem solving when
you're making art so what I'm going to
do is walk you guys through a few
projects this first one I'm real my
wrist about this anybody has ever seen
me talk now so I let go a little bit
overboard on demos so this is the
seventh thing I have plugged into my
computer right now and it's upside down
it's not even USB either alright so
here's what we're going to do this its
work in progress number 2 30 30
deep breath everybody mostly me
there it is okay all right if we look up
yonder we look up here as I'm going over
this color palette right we're getting
different things on here you can I
probably can't see that very well here's
the thing like I'm running around in
this this is a node project it's a nerd
snowed server a note client it's picking
up what pixels I'm sort of going over
with my mouse and think of this is like
a really weird aspect ratio screen but
then if I go outside of the browser it's
still working and that's the power of
node man it's it's amazing it will like
you can run it on the lowest server or
the lowest like server and like
operations on your computer so the
reason why I wonder this is because I
actually don't tell anybody from my work
but I want to take this I want to hang
it up at work over the weekend and give
everybody on my team the client software
for this so hopefully it'll look a
little something like this again some
fingers crossed okay so this is like
five this is a recording session of like
five different mouse points I knew that
wasn't going to work you son of a be so
imagine you know a lot of different
piece oh I'm up on stage imagine all
these like flying around and it's really
amazing piece of art that's being
created like accidentally in the
background over time that nobody's
really working towards but there's an
amazing there's an amazing like piece of
art that's going on the background its
community driven so oh ok start
unplugging some of these things so
here's the thing this is a work in
progress so why show you guys this a
couple reasons so one I I think it's
important to show things like as you're
working on them anybody can go on and
post a highlight reel on their Instagram
but I think it's really cool to do small
incremental pieces because when you're
making art even this steps towards the
final product are all presumably all
beautiful and they're worth sharing and
this is a true work in progress because
this is it 330 p.m. Monday the day
before I left this is it in a suitcase
at 5 45 p.m. and this is me working on
it that day and this is me earlier this
morning like running around in my hotel
room like putting this together and like
over here so again I just want to show
you that don't be afraid when you're
doing art to show to people and get
opinions and to share it with the world
all artists have sketchbooks this is a
van Gogh sketchbook that was recently
uncovered even these are beautiful even
these are amazing artists used to have
sketchbooks like this now we have
sketchbooks like your code pen sketch
book or just a giant messy folder on
your on your computer so when I posited
at the beginning its i like to use code
and are you like use art to learn more
code what i want to do is as i show
these projects talk about the things
that i learned that i wouldn't have
normally gotten to learn in my day to
day in my day-to-day work life first
things first bitwise operators i sort of
used them by copy pasting them out of
stack overflow but now I actually
understand them and being able to push
products oh boy being able to push
pixels down this strip required me to
understand bitwise operators a little
bit better than I used to LED dithering
our eyes are amazing they evolutionary
evolutionarily evolved to get the
smaller it said notice the smallest low
light changes so when you turn on an LED
that like one percent actually makes it
look like it's like seventeen percent so
I do work on look-up tables and an
inverse function I'm gonna level that
out so LEDs actually look like they grow
and shrink or the brightness gross and
shrink properly I learned all about Ram
swaps on Raspberry Pi because if you've
ever tried to build something like fan
MJS on a Raspberry Pi you're running a
memory real quick so I had to learn a
whole bunch of stuff there's a lot of
these like learning slides so I
apologize to everybody over here also I
want to say thank you because I came in
this morning not sure if this project
was going to work but I had some amazing
help earlier today so thanks so that's a
project it's
work in progress and the next couple are
sort of finished products this is from a
year ago or probably about six months
ago so this is my buddy Chris hearth and
he and he's a designer he's a print
designer and obviously I'm a developer
and he and I were hanging out we're like
let's make something this weekend let's
do something creative and artistic that
he's never done before which is
basically most things because again he's
just getting into the creative code side
so we decided I had had glitch art on
the mind for a lot of reasons XOXO had
just been had just passed and that was
the theme and so thought let's make
something glitchy so when you think
about glitch art you can do one of two
things you can take the actual rendered
image and like take chunks of it and
smear it or move them around or whatever
or you can do the deep dive getting into
the actual guts of the image I'll start
messing around with it so that's the
path that we chose ok demo number two
let's corrupt some data ok so if we look
at this most nervous speaker ever jpg
you guys may notice or you guys may
recognize him so we take this and we
open it up in our favorite text editor
this is what a JPEG looks like everybody
whatever they could you start changing
some of these numbers now some people
deep in take a breath give me a hex
value a I heard in you who said
so many years ago the JavaScript like
introduction let somebody give me
another hex value 1221 all right we'll
do it 82 uh I heard be let's see what
this looks like okay all right cool
certain get a little a little
interesting what happens if we take
let's say this chunk down here let's say
this is this is probably beard area
let's run it all up here let's drop it
in yonder rule okay well we broke that
one we'll talk about that so well Chris
arathin I did is we decided to take this
idea of corrupting the underlying
information of JPEGs and let's turn it
into a bot that listens for your
listeners for your tweet at it and then
not only takes your avatar and glitches
it out but it takes your avatar glitches
it out stylistically over time and makes
an animation out of it that's weird what
does that look like glad you all asked
so if we look at some of these if you
tweet at glitch avatar glitch here's one
this couple in here they're fun it's a
little bit more subtle a little bit
something a little crazy so if anybody
wants to test that legal avatar glitch
feel free to after the talk pay
attention so there because it's working
with chris earth he said like let me
sort of design the way it's these
glitches work and so we came up with
some of their very subtle and some that
are crazy and it was a really really
good I had a really good time working
with Chris arf so what did I learn well
as you can see if you just start messing
around with JPEGs you can like corrupt
them really quickly so I had to open up
a tech manual and read about how JPEGs
work I had to read about the headers and
JPEGs and what you can change what you
can't change so we knew that we could
get decent looking glitch art generative
Lee as it came back I would never have
had to do that in my regular job so
that's
that's a real real awesome win I'll swim
about buffers and actually how to make
animated gifs so this is something I've
actually used several times since then
so it's part of this process of doing
something fun and interesting and being
excited about it and then using it going
forward Christophe learned about how to
make BOTS they he had done a little bit
of creative coding but he never done
anything it sort of SAT there and waited
and responded based on input so it was a
really fun thing to do and then we took
these learnings we flipped it we turned
into a teachable moment so we went to a
local meetup and we talked about the
project and we actually launched it live
there it failed completely I took I took
a couple hours at night and like retold
it and pushed it up but we ended up
talking about it me from a designer know
me from a developer standpoint him from
a designer standpoint like where we hit
came on that spectrum and the things he
learned the things that I learned
speaking of which I am the I'm a
co-organizer of that meetup group pdx
creative coders along with these three
gentlemen and we're a group of now
almost 500 artists and developers and
hackers and designers that get together
and make cool art generative Lee we make
music who make all kinds of really cool
things and there's a few projects from
one of our hack days and I encourage you
all to find one of these near you I love
that way fix ejs cool so that's us like
a small weekend project let's talk about
a big project a big long long project
how many of you guys nope wrong slide
this is that how many of you guys know
Ben Purdy sorry that was a weird
question this is ben Purdy he's a friend
of mine I used to work with him an
instrument he left started his own
creative studio called Globox in
portland and he did i get together on
wednesdays and we jam we make cool art
cool projects creative code hack with
some hardware and Cascadia jess was
coming up last year and they're having
an interactive JavaScript art gallery so
he and I thought let's make something
cool for this
oh weird so we knew there's gonna be a
lot of in the browser projects and yeah
I wanted to make something physical and
outside of the browser so set their way
brainstormed we came up with this idea
Plinko do you guys know Plinko from the
price is right this is my favorite this
is probably everybody's favorite we said
to take this game and use the nostalgia
and the physics of it combine it with
JavaScript and turn it into a digital
canvas for generative art it sounds
weird and it was and it was hard and
it's you can't just go like find on the
internet how to make a generative pixel
Plinko board there's no like steps for
that so it's a lot of exploration had to
learn a lot of things a lot of stumbling
blocks but we ended up making it I took
a like I said it took a lot longer than
we thought it was going to and that's
one of the things with makes these weird
creative code projects as they often
take a lot longer than you sort of think
because there's a lot of gotchas along
the way it's a lot of repetition there's
a t5 pegs way to do a lot of things 85
times we have a ton of stop-motion
photography this is photography video
and then we finally got it done and we
actually put it in a couple galleries in
the last couple months and the response
has been amazing people love it kids
adults they sort of don't really
understand what it is they read the
instructions they take one of the pucks
and they walk up and they drop it and
then you see them turn around go oh yes
it's just awesome then they go pick up
another one and usually like two or
three and they drop all three and see
and to see what happens but this is
another one of those things about making
art is that if you do in the physical
space you actually going to see people
enjoying it and interacting with it and
if you make even if you make something
beautiful on the on the on a website you
don't get to see that you know
one-to-one relationship with the person
who's actually consuming that art so
what did I learn here well I didn't have
to learn about rendering jeff's we
already talked about that learn that
from avatar glitch but I learned a whole
lot other stuff a lot of hardware stuff
stuff a little bit of software stuff we
ended up coming up then packaged up what
we did for the
projection mapping which is all done in
JavaScript and he released it as a
standalone library which is amazing so
if anybody does projection mapping you
should check that out but this whole
project was JavaScript if we go back
this is all JavaScript this is mostly
node this is all JavaScript avatar
glitch 100% JavaScript this was about
ninety nine point seven percent
JavaScript and you wouldn't think if we
go back looking at this you wouldn't
think that this would be JavaScript but
it's a full full screen Chrome browser
with canvas it's a node back in that's
running inside of the little kiosk it
tweets you if you put your little here
or twitter handle in it'll tweet you at
an animation of your run one hundred
percent 99.7 percent JavaScript so all
of you can make art because hopefully
you understand javascript is you're at a
javascript conference okay we're going
to wrap this up my timer went out so I
don't actually know how much time I have
we're going to assume like 27 more
minutes I don't know I'm just going to
start rambling so again anybody that's
seen my talks before knows that this
final parts always a little rough
because this is homework homework what
yes homework you guys have to do this
not really not contractually so I'm many
of you guys a couple options for making
homework or for making some things and
the reason I want to give you guys this
option is each one of these should take
you one to two hours I would love for
you guys just to carve off a little bit
of time for your day to day and just try
something new and try flexing a
different part of your brain and try
just exploring a creative path we think
of this stuff as expressive instead of
functional programming we I don't know
we the greater community so the first
option is uncontacted I that I run that
is publicly accessible web sockets that
you can connect to and none of these
parameters really tell you what they are
ABCDEF and the point here is these
change over time they change according
to rules and they change it certain
patterns but none of these tell you what
to do with the data you could use D to
control color for something or speed or
rotation at number of particles
same thing with any of these different
parameters it doesn't matter whatever
you make with this is a hundred percent
your personality coming out in this so
whatever you have in your head whatever
your identity is your politics your
personal beliefs all that comes out as
art just like traditional just like fine
art I want to give you guys a couple of
examples from this so these are two
Portland centric artists so this is
libby libby white and this is one thing
she did I don't know which of these
parameters are controlling what like
whether they're looking at each other
how wide they are how tall they are but
something in that math or something in
that those parameters movie ground is
creating this and this is lucas's get
some sounds
a lot of sine and cosine here Web Audio
API multiple JavaScript these have two
people with entirely different
background entirely different
personalities they're creating art with
the same code or the same like
underlying heartbeat that's option
number one go-to in context make
something option number two is code pin
code pin who here knows code pin yes
there's a way over there it's great code
pin is rad we talked about sketchbooks
earlier now artists have sketchbooks
code pin is basically a global digital
open collection of sketchbooks and
that's great you can go in and you can
look and see what people are doing how
they're getting things to look and move
a certain way and if you go to the
homepage of code pin if you don't know
they elevate all kinds of rad projects
some are functional like button
rollovers but some are really weird
JavaScript or CSS experimentations you
can go in there and learn the math and
see how they're sort of twisting the
things that you normally think of in one
way and making them into something
completely different go to code pin fork
something play with it find something
that is visually interesting and play
with it that's option two option number
three is find a code group they're
everywhere mostly except for a lot of
Asia and all of Africa and most of South
America okay bad example but anyway
they're everywhere and you guys are all
from all over the United States and all
over the world go and find a creative
code group preferably a language
agnostic one because it would be great
if you can get in a room and talk to
people that do cinder and open
frameworks and open CV and all kinds of
cool things sort of cross pollinate
ideas and not just developers but also
artists and go to your local JavaScript
meetups and just start talking about art
I guarantee you from personal experience
if you just go to a local javascript
meetup you start talking about art
people are going to want to talk to you
and they're going to want to make art
with you that's how I've made some of my
favorite people that I know no that's
how I've made friends with some of my
favor
people in Portland and if you can't find
one start one it's really easy meetup
com is free you need you and just you
and you go find a place and you just
start making art tell people about it
and they'll come probably again no
guarantees nope that's backwards hold on
that's it how much time do I have we'll
just assume this is in five minutes I
don't have any more I don't have any
more wisdom to share I'm just going to
wrap this up so thank you guys this is
me I'm John Brown and I'm making art
here and here and here i have an SEO
problem John Brown is rough there's a
lot of us did you guys know inspector
gadget's real name is John Brown it's a
fun fact so I'm making art here all the
time and we just saw JavaScript CSS and
JavaScript and I just want to do a
terrible plug for myself but I'm
actually working on this hundred a
project right now where I'm exploring
CSS and just raw gives no nesting no
associated styling no IDs or anything
and just seeing what I can do with those
over a hundred days and I've done some
really cool stuff I'm doing one a day
some are great summer terrible but you
should check it out and they're all
posted all along here hashtag make our
everyday and that's all thanks everybody